hello everyone and welcome back to some
great classical chess uh in norway chess
2021 uh we're gonna show two games once
again as you guys enjoyed the previous
video so much not the previous but one
before that where i squeezed two games
into one uh and since it was such an
amazing day like round seven uh we are
going to show all the classical games
they were played so the first game that
we're showing uh yanni palmish versus
arianthari ended the second game of
course karakin vs firuja uh let's dive
straight into it and we're we have quite
a lot to discuss so here nipple with the
white pieces opens with e4 uh toddy goes
for c5 he uh goes for the sicilian
defense uh sorry that's not true i'm
showing you a different game uh a nipple
actually opened with c4 he went for the
english opening um uh karjakin went for
for e4 uh but here we have e5 so the
english is on the board we have knight
to c3 and now usually black just goes
knight to f6 or knight to c6 but here we
have bishop to b4 uh the so-called
kramnik shiro counter attack where
you're baiting white to go knight to d5
it's not really a bait because it's the
best thing white can do of course you're
not going to allow
black to just to mess up your pawn
structure so knight to d5 and now bishop
back to e7 so what's the idea here uh
kind of allowing this knight to be on d5
instead of on c3 where we're going to
play knight to f6 and then we're going
to have pressure on this knight on d5
that's kind of the
uh the idea so knight to f3 attacking e5
we have d6 defending and g3 now
preparing to fianchetto our light square
bishop and now knight to f6 where we're
already threatening to pick up the
knight and the mess up uh
white's pawn structure a little bit uh
and now you could go for something like
knight captures on e7 where maybe queen
captures on e7 and then you get this
position where nothing is really
happening white has won the bishop pair
very early on or you could go for just
continue the development with bishop to
g2 it has also been played before but
nepo just goes back knight to c3 he says
i'm having none of that i'm skipping
your preparation and it is now already
as of move six uh that we have a
completely new game sorry about not
telling you when it was a completely new
game in the previous video but i have to
check sometimes if anyone even cares
about that and also i forgot about it so
here after knight to c3 we have c5 so
closing the center having very nice
control of d4 and nipple might have
ideas of doing the same
we have bishop to g2 we have h6 uh and
now d3 uh we have bishop to e6 and now
knight to d2
so what do you what do you play here uh
well queen to d7 just continuing
development and since white finn get to
the light square bishop of course we are
at some point playing bishop to h3 and
we want to trade off white's very strong
defender here on g2 so both players just
castle we have castle's castles uh and
now knight back to d5 asking do you
maybe want to capture now on d5 and then
yes you will mess up my pawn structure
but then it's sort of
then it's going to be sort of like a
bone in black's throat where you're not
going to be
developing your pieces you know to
natural squares you're going to have to
play something like knight a6 knight to
c7
and so on but uh tari says that's not a
problem he captures it knight captures
on d5 c captures on d5 and now bishop to
h3 you want to get rid of this bishop
either way so e4 by nipple and now
bishop captures on g2 we have king
captures and now f5 and we can safely
assume that thori got exactly what he
wanted out of the opening some you know
double edged position where he can play
for something but that's uh that can be
very dangerous against the player like
nipple because if someone goes for
double h position it it's definitely
yanim ponyshi
and here you could consider a lot of
things just maybe you know queen to h5
maybe you want to play b3 if you can do
a dark square bishop on this diagonal so
many things are possible here but nepo
just goes f4
he says it's not a problem i already
played g3 i'm gonna play f4 as well uh
and you still have to finish your
development so here we have e captures
on f4 and now uh one might can see a
continue a move like uh consider a move
like rook captures on e4 but here we
have g captures on on f4 and nipple says
bring it on
so here uh again you have to start
developing at some point but tari for
the moment just keeps
the the tension we have bishop to f6 and
it's not easy for white to execute this
e5 move because if the pawn captures
queen will capture on d5 the king is in
g2 so you have to first to do something
about this so we have knight to c for
now and finally knight to a6 tari will
now bring the knight and the other rook
into the game uh and now uh like i said
e5 there's it's much too early for that
if we try something like d captures and
even d6 it's uh kind of maybe possible
but not really because we're just going
to capture on f4 and now we have to
constantly worry about b5 then our pawn
will fall if the knight gets kicked away
so we might stop it with a4 but then
black can play g5 and it's black who's
attacking here not white so after knight
to a6 we have queen to f3 now you have
support for e5 because the queen will be
guarding the d5 pawn uh and now uh we
have rooked a rook a to e8 if you go b5
right away which is i know something you
guys really want to do we play knight to
a5 and then the c6 square is available
for the knight and then from c6 we are
also covering e5 so this doesn't really
stop e5 if anything it maybe even
enhances it uh so after queen to f3 we
have rook 8 to e8 and now queen to h3
uh stopping any captures because the
queen and d7 would hang so uh and also
just threatening to pick up this pawn so
bishop to d4 now the rook also helps out
with the defense of this pawn uh and now
comes bishop to e3 countering black's a
very strong bishop here now
but now the position is much much
different than it was so feel free to
pause the video and try to find uh the
only winning attempt for tari while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
uh b5 now is the correct way to go uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show yes it is still b5 so
it's not it's not exactly a winning
maneuver but it's you know uh like a
crossroad where this road can take you
to victory and the other road maybe
won't uh and now it's incredibly strong
because now if you go knight to day five
which was possible in all of those lines
then we simply play bishop captures on
a3 queen captures and knight
sorry knight to b4 now and there are too
many threats knights to c2 this fork
will win you material there's also
knight captures on d5 you will not be
able to capture because the queen is now
an e3 and the only way to avoid all of
this is to move the queen away from
there but now we play c4 and now black
will have
excellent excellent winning chances
because uh well you either get a
beautiful pass pawn here or you capture
just with the knight or if pawn captures
here you get a beautiful pass pawn here
as the rook will already be guarding
this so white cannot uh keep an eye on
everything so b5 incredible move and
tari played it so here of course moving
the knight makes no sense like we've
just shown nipple captures the bishop
but now still just b captures on c4
saying your bishop is still hanging so
nipple brings it back bishop to c3 and
now c captures on d3
so what do you do if queen captures and
attacks the knight kind of saying okay
you cannot capture and create a pass
pawn because the knight is hanging uh we
can just move the knight which tempo the
queen is attacked and even if black
captures we first capture on e4 create
the past pawn and only after the white
queen moves then we recapture on b4 and
now we have a monster pass pawn here on
e4 black is of course much much better
so after c captures on d3 nipple says
all right i have to you know
do some damage control here uh or maybe
even you know not abandon ship just yet
but do some damage control uh he goes
rook to g1 now preparing to put some
pressure along the uh semi-open g file
and now rook to f7 tari just adds
another defender so he doesn't have to
worry about stuff like that we have
kinked the h1
and only now rook captures on e4 how you
uh
so what do you play here of course uh
this uh you could also consider
something like this uh yes you do have
to connect it past pawns now but then
maybe queen captures on h6 can be can be
somewhat annoying now having a you know
a triple attack here and uh could happen
but it's very complicated so he goes for
rook captures on e4 it's a much more
direct way to play
and now uh what does nipple play here
well obviously you could go for queen
captures on h6 but there is no follow-up
here
because the
g7 square is just defended three times
so here we have rook to g6 now nepal
wants the double rooks and the g file
and then play queen to h6 and then four
of his pieces will be going after that
g7 square
but now the problem is that he has one
one move that no one would expect and
that is rook captures on f4 and for a
very good reason you will realize it on
the next move rook eight to g1 now with
full pressure are going for that g7
queen captures on h6 we've kind of
reached a position from the thumbnail
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only move for tari that
wins the game while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
you cannot stop queen captures on h6 and
all of these threats so one thing you
can do is just uh put a rook in between
white's rooks so congratulations to
everyone who found this because this is
the only way to victory and now the
problem is if you go queen captures on
h6 nothing really happens we're just
going to capture one of the rooks and
after rook captures yes you're attacking
it three times but we are defending it
three times and we have a pass pawn here
so yeah we would be completely winning
for black so instead after rook to g4
nipple has to capture it we have rook
one captures on g4 f captures on g4 and
now queen captures on d3 uh again
he has to do some damage control
eliminating this past pawn uh is kind of
crucial here so now knight to b4 sing
all right you can capture here but then
one of your very strong attackers is
just out of the game and nipple is down
two pawns so of course he cannot allow
this we have queen to e4
and now comes rook to e7 putting
pressure on the queen here queen to f4
uh and now knight captures on d5 going
after the queen uh the thing is you
could have played knight to d3 as well
it's a very tricky move and white really
doesn't have a good move here uh
capturing for example on d6 just runs
into queen f5 and there's no defense
against queen to f1 it's a game over so
instead after queen to f4 okay tardy
played knight captures on d5 it's still
justice winning queen to c for now
pinning the knight uh but uh doesn't
really matter we have uh queen to f5
defending the knight now comes rook
captures on g4 and the king the h7
nicely on pinning and now we will very
happily eliminated this bishop here so
of course nipple moves that bishop to d2
and now queen to f3 with check we have
kinked the g1 now comes queen to g
acquaint to d1 with check
and
i'm not sure if this is where uh nipple
resigned it could be that he resigned
here but uh yeah i i i'm calling it that
he resigned here of course i i i i don't
think he would move the uh king uh and
then you know allow the capture of this
bishop because after king g2 queen
capture san diego comes with check your
knight is defended and of course you are
getting destroyed here uh but the just
you know not uh you know uh tell you
guys uh something that's not true i will
check really quickly uh at what moment
did he resign uh so yeah yeah after
queen to d1 it was in this position that
yanni pominshi resigned to the game and
a very nice victory for aryanthari which
is also his first victory in the norway
chess
so very very good for him
so that's uh nipple versus starting hope
you guys enjoyed that but now we're
gonna check out the other game as well
it's a rather short one so stay tuned uh
let's check it out so the next game is
uh
sorry
uh karjakin versus ferugia and it's uh
quite quite an impressive one so let's
check it out uh sergey with the white
pieces opens with e4 you guys already
know this because i thought that was the
move for the previous game uh c5 by
ferruja of course he goes for the
sharpest reply possible to the e4 the
sicilian defense knight to f3 we have d6
then the d4 now striking in the center
captures captures knight to f6 knight to
c3 and now of course these guys are not
joking around the absolute sharpest
possible the neighbor sicilian is on the
board and here you could play a lot of
things um
still the the most popular are just
bishop moves like bishop e3 bishop g5
bishop b to bishop c4 like any any move
is possible here but h3 is becoming more
and more popular amongst the elite
because it's called the atoms attack and
it just allows you to very very quickly
get that g4 g5 in and uh if you're not
really really familiar with all of the
lines you can
you know go wrong very very easily so
here uh furuja goes e5 chases away the
knight and now usually the knight is
retreated to e2 but uh karjakin just
goes knight f3 he says i don't really
care what they usually do
bishop to e7 and now g4 so preparing
that g5 the knight will have to move
we're going to win the d5 square for our
own knight so h6 stopping this and now
rook to g1 not joking around karjakin is
going for the kill
and now uh there are some games where
knight to c6 was played b5 is a known
move but ferruja goes queen to c7 and it
is now again already as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game so uh what
do you do here well
of course the question is do we do we
just uh strike with the g5 and while it
is possible uh
it's uh hard to say if uh if it's the
correct thing to do for example g5 we're
gonna capture knight captures here and
we constantly have pressure we control
e6 we control f7 luckily black controls
the c4 square so you don't have bishop
to c4 but even ideas like knight to c6
are possible allowing bishop to c4 and
now knight to d8 so black can even play
like this df7 square nicely defended the
queen attacking the bishop here uh the
niger is a very very rich opening but uh
karjakin doesn't go for this he goes for
knight to h4 he really likes the f5
square for his knight as an outpost and
firuja prevents this we have g6 sort of
a weakening of the position but you have
to you know
play something we have knights to g2 now
shifting the knights to e3 and then you
will really have very nice control of
the d5 square we have bishop to e6 also
developing a piece gaining more control
of the
d5 square and now knight to e3
we have knight beat to d7 and now h4
so again aimed at
winning that the d5 square we want to
play g5 kick away the defender of the d5
square and then uh you know just put a
knight on this beautiful outpost queen
to c6 firuja not only gains more control
of d5 but now puts pressure on the e for
pawn so you have to defend this pawn
queen to f3 defending it and now knights
the c5 adding another attacker here so
karjakin defends it bishop to g2
and now even knight to a4 and this is
where uh the magic really happens so
it's a really really crazy position much
like you can expect from a night or uh
and uh well you you now uh have kind of
released control of the d5 square a
little bit by black and you should put
something on d5 the question is what uh
probably this knight because this knight
is kind of busy guarding the g4 pawn so
what would happen if knight c to d5 uh
well we would see something like bishop
captures e captures on d5 attacking the
queen and after queen to b6 uh we would
get this position where yeah it's a fine
position for both black has a lot a lot
of pressure here on the queen side rook
the c8 is coming even more pressure on
the queen side and uh
who could who could play this with white
if you ask our good friend the engine he
just says king of white and white is
perfectly fine but i mean
uh
you know
we can't just play like that i mean if
we play like this then uh you know it
would be chaos uh so of course he
doesn't go for this he goes for a
different line he plays knight e to the
e5 instead but now it's a little bit
weird you've released control of the g4
pawn and while it's impossible to
capture it with the bishop because
knight captures an f6 with check and
then you just lose this bishop
it is possible to capture it with the
knight yeah so it's a it's a fine move
and now it's a question what uh
white had in mind probably maybe
capturing an e7 and then king captures
on e7 but black shouldn't really care
the the king will be very safe on e7 as
he often is in a lot of the lines of the
night earth but instead of this knight
captures on g4 firuja plays knight
captures on c3 we have knight captures
on f6 with check bishop captures and
queen captures and f6 with the check and
now both ferrucci's knight and the rook
are hanging so what's happening here uh
well nothing really that's the crazy
part firuja just plays king to d7
now the rooks get connected the rooks
are defending each other and the knight
isn't really hanging if you capture the
knight then we just play queen captures
on c3 check and black wins the game you
don't really have a good move here if
king e2 even bishop to c for king d1
we're going to play queen to d4 check
harass that white king a little bit
kingy one only now capture the rook with
the threat of just queen captures on c1
so uh white is completely lost here and
also regarding that f7 pawn so there's
really no counter play here so instead
uh karjakin says all right that's
obviously not a very good idea so maybe
my whole idea of bringing this knight to
d5 wasn't all that impressive but i'm
already here so i have to continue
playing he plays g5 now if h captures
the bishop captures you might have some
access to the e7 square uh but ferruccio
just plays knight captures on e4 there
there's no way to defend all of the
pawns either you lose this pawn or you
lose this pawn it's also attacked twice
so there's
no hope of that so he has to go for some
activity but now like i said knight
captures on e4 attacks the queen so
queen to f3 now with a double attack on
the knight and now finally d5 and you
know what we say about black when he
plays d5 in the in the night or if it's
uh even if it's an equal position you
know you know that black is better but
here when it's a better position d5 is
just you know it's it's hard to watch uh
so queen back to d1 you also have to
keep an eye on the c2 pawn and now queen
to b6 uh threatening checkmate i mean
wha what is happening here and now queen
to e2 is a solid reply you can kind of
defend this pawn but it's a very very
passive then rook the c8 is coming you
can double rooks on the c file it's
going to be very ugly uh so instead we
have bishop to e3 karjakin wants to
activate his pieces and he's offering
the b2 pawn for that
maybe he can get some rook to be one
rook captures and b7 action in there but
first is not a problem queen captures on
b2 we have bishop captures on e4 first
eliminating one of the attackers uh and
while it's impossible to capture this
due to the pin uh we have queen to be
for check this is how he uh saves the
saves the day c3 defending and now queen
captures on e4 and now rook to b1 going
after rook captures on b7 but first
doesn't care he just plays h captures on
g5 so like the honey badger uh and what
do you do here yes you could go for rook
captures on b7 but this is kind of what
black wants he's going to play king the
e8 and this rook is now just a liability
here you want to play d4 and then you're
going to attack the bishop the rook so
you're going to have to waste another
move just moving that rook so instead
first we have rook to b4 attacking the
queen and now d4
so now you can't really do anything
about this c captures on for and now uh
comes the move that really really shows
how how strong furuja is uh king the e8
so that was the only way basically to
save the game uh give up a pawn
temporarily and then move the king
because now you don't have to worry
about your king occupying the same file
as the queen and of course this pawn now
cannot move because the rook would hang
so what can you play here he starts with
h captures on g5 but now rook to h3 a
lot of pressure here uh even ideas like
rook captures on e3 come to mind so kink
the e king to d2 if king to e2 we don't
care we just play rook c8 and we're
bringing a rook to c2 so he tries to
rook the d2 instead
looks very weird but you know there is
just nothing better we have bishop to f5
now going after a queen to d3 check so
queen to b3 guarding this uh but now
rook to c8 and there is really not all
that much you can do now here with white
rook the c1 was played offering the
trade of rooks and uh black happily
obliges we wrote characters king
captures now rook to h1 check king the
d2 and now b5 completely making this
rook useless here and what do you play
here with white
d5 was played opening up a discovery
here on white's queen but the just queen
to f3 and he was in this position
unmoved 35 uh sorry on move 34 that
sergey karjakin resigned the game and
another great victory for alireza firuja
in classical time format so here you
resign it's uh sort of almost like a two
swung
i mean it's completely lost but uh
there's no move that you can make
the rook doesn't have a single square
where wherever you move the rook we can
just capture it uh the queen can't move
because you have to keep an eye on these
two squares uh otherwise you're just
dead lost and there's really nothing to
try uh if you try something like a3
which is you know just trying to keep
everything where it is we just play rook
to b1 and it's game over you don't have
access to these two squares you have to
play queen to a4 and not just queen
captures on d5 so the queen cannot keep
an eye on everything king e2 and now we
just finish it bishop d3 check king d2
bishop to c4 a nice discovery check king
to c2 now queen to d3 will be checkmate
or if you try something like uh
there's nothing to try but let's say you
move the bishop just asking black how do
you play this then even ideas like
bishop to d3 are possible of course
you're not trading queens you're
preparing now just to end the game and
of course if white captures this rook to
d1 check and again it's a very it's over
very quickly queen captures king b2 rook
to b1 will be checkmate
so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
that after queen to f3 uh karaoke
resigned the game uh so wonderful
wonderful classical games by both tari
and firuja and what does this mean for
our standings let's check it out here
are the standings uh rapport still
leading the tournament half a point
ahead of magnus carlsen who caught up to
him a little bit but two more rounds to
go we'll see if rapport can take it all
away and just win this amazing classical
tournament then we have furuja who is
now in third place as
nepal lost the game uh followed by nepo
karyakin and aryanthari who doubled his
points as he was only on three points
but now we're winning classical it's uh
now six points but you know he can still
win two classical games so maybe he gets
on 12 points uh you know good things can
still happen for him
uh so
that's uh the game or rather games hope
you guys uh enjoyed that um
uh really really a wonderful stuff i'm
really looking forward to the next few
days and how all this will unwind uh so
stay tuned for that uh hopefully we can
have as many classical enjoyable games
as possible armageddon is nice but uh i
mean classical is classical so once
again hope you guys enjoyed that uh i
would like to thank customchairs.com tom
darrell isaac hits graph francis heir
and uh siri gotham yoshua for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
rest of the tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and sorry for
a bit of a longer video again see you
soon